[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginatevi seduti sotto questo cielo
stellato in una terza notte d'estate
adesso pensate
lo spazio tra noi e le stelle lassù è
vuoto purtroppo no è pieno di spazzatura
nella vita di ogni giorno facciamo uso
dei satelliti artificiali più di quanto
ce ne rendiamo conto
i satelliti artificiali vengono per
esempio usati per fare le previsioni del
tempo
lunedì prima di partire per venire qui a
barletta ho consultato le previsioni del
tempo e son venuto con impermeabile
ombrello perché oggi pomeriggio dovrebbe
piovere il navigatore dal nostro
automobile usa i segnali provenienti da
una rete di satelliti gps quando
guardiamo la televisione
usiamo i satelliti per trasferire i
segnali i satelliti sono anche usati per
garantire la sicurezza nazionale
tutti questi satelliti orbitano intorno
alla terra ma non tutte le orbite sono
utili per i nostri usi le orbite più
utilizzate sono quella a 36 mila
chilometri intorno all'equatore orbita
geostazionaria e le orbite età e 600 e
1000 chilometri intorno ai poli delle
orbite polari queste orbite potrebbero
essere paragonate a delle autostrade
sulle quali viaggiano tutti i satelliti
di cui facciamo uso ogni giorno si
autostrade però senza autovelox nei
limiti di velocità si può andare veloci
quanto si vuole
per avere un'idea dell'efficacia di
queste orbite dell'uso di queste orbite
possiamo paragonarlo a delle autostrade
del cielo la data d'inizio di tutte
dell'uso di tutte queste orbite e il 4
ottobre 1957 più o meno la mia data di
nascita ma e questa è la data di lancio
del primo satellite artificiale
sputnik questa è la data di inizio del
uso dello spazio ma purtroppo anche
l'inizio del problema della spazzatura
spaziale
e sì perché una volta lanciati nello
spazio e dopo aver terminato la loro
missione tutti questi satelliti e i
missili che sono stati usati per portare
i satelliti in orbita sono destinati a
rimanere lassù per un tempo molto lungo
o addirittura per sempre pensate se
avessimo lasciato in autostrada tutte le
automobili che abbiamo comprato fino ad
oggi invece di mandarli in demolizione
oggi non saremmo più in grado di guidare
per tutti i veri vi per via di tutti i
veicoli in disuso nello spazio cui tutto
è più grande
anche il problema della spazzatura
infatti il problema viene ingrandito dal
fatto che i satelliti in disuso
esplodono per via dei carburanti residuo
che hanno a bordo si scontrano con altri
satelliti o ad altri detriti con il
rischio di generare un effetto valanga
che può rendere un'orbita completamente
inutilizzabile lo spazio intorno al
nostro pianeta si sta così riempiendo di
satellite in disuso parti di missili
arti di satelliti esplosi in questa
animazione
notate la distribuzione dei detriti
intorno alla pianeta terra
i detriti in orbita circolare più grande
sono quelli in orbita stazionaria e
notate l'alta densità di detriti nelle
fasce nelle quote più basse intorno al
pianeta terra
tutti questi detriti nello spazio
viaggiano a velocità elevatissime 7,5
chilometri al secondo
equivalenti a 27 mila chilometri all'ora
immaginatevi in un treno che viaggia a
27 mila chilometri all'ora
andreste da roma a new york in 15 minuti
neanche il tempo di finire di leggere il
giornale
a queste velocità anche un piccolo
detrito è come un proiettile con
l'energia equivalente a quella di una
bomba a mano
l'impatto di una sferetta di alluminio
di poco meno di 2 grammi alla velocità
di 7 km al secondo genera un cratere
profondo più di 5 centimetri in un
blocco di alluminio in quest'altra
immagine invece vedete il pannelli
solari di un satellite per
l'osservazione della terra che viaggiava
a 800 km di quota che sono stati colpiti
da un piccolo detrito il risultato è un
grande foro nel pannello di più di dieci
centimetri indicato dalla freccia rossa
se questo piccolo detrito avesse colpito
il serbatoio del satellite
il satellite sarebbe esploso con
generazione di tantissimi altri detriti
vabbè direte voi ma lo spazio è così
grande la probabilità che un detrito e
un satellite si incontrino si scontrino
è davvero bassa qual è il problema in
realtà dal 1957 ad oggi
ci sono state più di 500 esplosioni in
orbita che hanno generato un'enorme
quantità di detriti
ad oggi si contano più di 34.000 detriti
34 mila oggetti più grandi di 10 cm 900
mila oggetti tra un centimetro e 10
centimetri di dimensioni e ben 166
milioni di oggetti più piccoli di un
centimetro e ciascuno di questi oggetti
come abbiamo visto prima ha la capacità
di distruggere un satellite è un po come
se sulle nostre autostrade avessimo
tantissimi detriti
ad oggi in orbita si contano 5mila
satelliti di cui solo duemila sono
funzionanti ma nel giro di pochi anni
questo numero di satelliti potrebbe
duplicarsi o addirittura triplicarsi
infatti oggi ci si parla di due nuovi
aspetti l'accesso allo spazio si sta
democratizzando e non è più una
prerogativa delle solite nazioni
tecnologicamente avanzate il costo dei
satelliti sta diminuendo e si parla del
lancio di costellazione di satelliti
ciascuna di queste costellazioni e
costituita da varie centinaia o
addirittura migliaia di satelliti per
poter continuare ad operare in sicurezza
tutti questi satelliti bisogna
continuamente sorvegliare lo spazio e
sapere in ogni istante dove si trovano
tutti i detriti
in tal modo possiamo spostare i
satelliti in orbita più sicura dove non
incontra detriti
il problema dei detriti i satelliti in
orbita bassa vengono fatti rientrare in
atmosfera
mentre i satelliti in orbita alta
vengono mantenuti in orbite di
parcheggio dove vi rimarranno per sempre
questo è una sorta di cimitero dello
spazio come dicevo prima dobbiamo
sorvegliare il lo spazio e la
sorveglianza viene fatta usando una rete
di grandi stazioni radar e telescopi
distribuiti un po dovunque sul globo
queste radere telescopi scrutano
continuamente il cielo ed informano
l'operatore del satellite
quando c'è una previsione di collisione
in tal modo l'operatore può mandare un
comando al satellite e spostare il
satellite in altra orbita pensate che
perfino la stazione spaziale
internazionale che al momento in orbita
a 400 chilometri con le sue 420
tonnellate deve di tanto in tanto
cambiare orbita per evitare l'impatto
con piccoli detriti dell'arrivo è il
caso di un gigante che deve spostarsi
per evitare l'impatto con un moscerino
quello che vedete adesso nell'immagine
voi pensate sia una stella cadente nella
notte di san lorenzo
ebbene no non esprimere alcun desiderio
non ne varrebbe la pena
si tratta in realtà del rientro di un
satellite in atmosfera
in questo specifico caso è il satellite
giapponese hayabusa che al rientro con
l'atmosfera all'impatto con l'atmosfera
a 80 km di quota si rompe in tante parti
e ciascuna di queste parti comincia a
bruciare per via dell'impatto con
l'atmosfera e l'attrito con le
particelle dell'atmosfera
in realtà però i satelliti che rientro
nell'atmosfera non bruciano
completamente ed alcune parti
raggiungono la superficie terrestre
questo è un esempio di una parte di
satellite che ha raggiunto la superficie
terrestre
in generale si tratta dei serbatoi dei
satelliti di che sono fatti di titanio o
di fibra di carbonio che hanno una
elevatissima temperatura di fusione e
quindi non bruciano all'attrito con
l'atmosfera
adesso guardiamo la fotografia so che
state pensando a quel ragazzo li vicino
alla sfera di metallo e caduta dal cielo
che rischiava corso
ebbene dovete pensare che la probabilità
di essere coinvolti in un incidente
automobilistico
per esempio venendo qui in teatro questa
mattina era di una in 4.500 la
probabilità di vincere il primo premio
della lotteria italia e una in dieci
milioni la probabilità di essere colpiti
da uno di questi detriti e una in mille
miliardi quindi praticamente impossibile
non ci dobbiamo preoccupare
dell'incolumità del ragazzo c'è invece
qualcos'altro di cui ci dobbiamo
preoccupare
che cosa possiamo fare per tutti quei
satelliti che non sono muniti dei motori
per poter rientrare in atmosfera e
quindi distruggersi questi satelliti
sono destinati a rimanere in orbita per
un tempo lunghissimo o addirittura per
sempre quindi costituiscono un rischio
per gli altri satelliti
ebbene c'è bisogno di un sistema per la
raccolta dei rifiuti spaziali
l'industria spaziale al momento sta
sviluppando satelliti attrezzati proprio
per la raccolta dei rifiuti spaziali
si tratta in realtà di una sorta di
camion bar sa che vedete ogni mattina in
giro per le strade a raccogliere
i rifiuti
questi satelliti sono equipaggiati con
bracci robotici come quello che vedete
adesso nell'immagine oppure con un
sistema di reti e arpioni che sono in
grado di catturare il satellite non più
funzionante in disuso e rientrare con
esso in atmosfera
oppure portarlo in un'orbita di
parcheggio dove vi rimarrà per sempre
questi sono in pratica ai nostri
operatori ecologici robotizzati che ci
aiuteranno a risolvere il problema della
spazzatura nello spazio
in conclusione possiamo dire che lo
spazio c'è molto molto utile ed è una
risorsa come lo sono gli oceani le
foreste il nostro sottosuolo solo
facendone un uso responsabile potremo
garantire i benefici dello spazio anche
per le generazioni future
in tal modo in quella terza notte
d'estate anche i nostri figli potranno
rivolgere gli occhi al cielo e invece di
giocare a riconoscere costellazioni di
detriti potranno giocare a riconoscere
costellazioni di meravigliose stelle
grazie
[Applauso]